hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one issue that
can close some confusions and troubles
for modern readers of Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics is the relationship
between virtue or the virtues in the
plural and when he's calling nature by
that meaning human nature the nature
that we we have and share in common as
human beings and part of the reason why
this ends up generating confusions is we
tend to think of nature as for example
our DNA you know what we're starting
with as human beings and the cultures
perhaps something additional to that we
also have kind of sloppy way of talking
where we say oh well that's just human
nature meaning that's the way human
beings tend to behave and that's a
somewhat different way of thinking about
it but we also lack quite often a
conception that is driving Aristotle
which is what a fully developed human
nature would look like and then it's not
the human nature that we're observing by
looking at all of our own fellow human
beings or engaging in introspection
unless we're pretty good people
in my case that's definitely not the
case sufficiently to be able to say I
understand a fully developed human
nature is like by just looking at my own
case so when we talk about the virtues
and vices what we're talking about there
just to remind ourselves our qualities
of a character or personality they are
stable they are chosen as as such they
are reliable you can expect a greedy
person to act greedy in most
circumstances they are not completely
determinative as it's possible there
could be exceptions but the exceptions
will prove the rule rather than being a
violation of the rule so the virtues and
vices they do not exist within us by
nature so Aristotle would be rejecting
for example ideas that human beings are
by their very nature bad or by their
very nature are good he would say human
nature is quite malleable in this
respect it all depends on how upbringing
and education and what you're starting
with your culture and also the choices
that you make how well those those sorts
of things play out but they don't come
into the world already having virtuous
or vicious dispositions as much as we
might like to think that our our kids
are better or worse than others
Aristotle would say no that's that's
just an illusion as a matter of fact
kids don't really have you know at the
stage of development that they are they
they can't be said to have virtues or
vices in any full-blown sense but just
the potential for it and this is
important we do him of the potential for
the virtues and the vices because of our
human nature so as Aristotle is going to
observe he's going to say we this is
very early on and mecha McCann
textbook tuners he says that we have the
virtues are engendered in us neither by
nature it's not a natural process that
produces virtue in us nor in violation
of nature it's not an anti natural
process that generates the virtues
within us nature gives us the capacity
or the potential that do not necessarily
actuality that this potential is brought
to actuality by habit the term there is
F those this is what the term we get
that things from because the Aristotle
thinks that a very important portion of
ethics is figuring out how we take
people who are not by nature virtuous
and gradually steer them towards virtue
in such a way Nia that it becomes part
of their nature it becomes second nature
and becomes something that they can
themselves choose for its own sake as
their good what we're trying to do is
put people in touch with a fully
developed human nature we're sort of
getting them on the way so how do we in
fact acquire the virtues Aristotle says
we acquire them by acting and responding
in virtuous ways so it's sort of fake it
till you make it but there is a make it
at the end of the thinking you don't
necessarily want to be just but you act
justly and if you do it long enough and
you don't just do it to you know avoid
punishment you will in fact make that
part of who you are it'll become a habit
for you what's going on there is an
actualization of a potential that is
there in our nature but which would be
undeveloped if we didn't take some sort
of stance if we didn't engage in a
deliberate intervention we would not
acquire that I'm going to make it a side
note here I often have students who will
you know read hurt you athletes
Plato or Aristotle or Augustine and then
they will imagine that there that these
thinkers are saying that we all have the
virtues and our disposal and we just
have to sort of like deep down inside
and find them that's not what Aristotle
thinks Aristotle thinks you come into
this world without any of the virtues
you may develop the beginnings of them
you may have what we'll talk about in
another video as the natural virtues
because of your temperament or something
like that but unless you actually work
at it and unless you probably have some
help from from other people and working
at it you're not going to develop them
it is not like the Acorn growing into an
oak it is more like sort of a system
that can actually make decisions about
itself and steers itself towards its
fuller development so we acquire the
virtues by acting or responding in the
right ways and I want to make another
note here too he does talk about the
virtues in relation to not only habits
or hex ace as well but also emotions the
pathway which include desire or appetite
and he also talks about in terms of
capacities Dunamis which returns that
sometimes as capacities were potential
now Aristotle does think that the
emotions are natural to us as human
beings unless there's something damaged
about our brains or something like that
we come to the world as babies ready to
feel emotions and we already start to
exhibit there's a variety of emotions in
childhood we don't really understand
them that well and some of them may not
be is fully developed for example desire
at Lithonia where appetite is going to
go into a lot of other channels once we
hit puberty and once we start seeing all
the other things
spirited desire anger will develop it in
other ways as well as we become more and
more conscious of justice and injustice
but for the most part the emotions are
there for us right some people feel that
more strongly by their temperament
some people feel them less strongly but
everybody basically has the toolbox or
the manifold of emotions we also have
air so says these capacities to feel the
emotions in certain ways so you know for
example to take temperament again some
people are more irritable than others
and that's just part of their makeup you
know this interesting because modern
science lately has been studying these
things and it found that that is
actually true and you can sometimes
predict certain outcomes very broad
senses if no interventions of her so the
capacities to feel emotions to feel joy
to feel sadness to feel anger to feel
surprised to feel fear you know all
those sorts of things that is natural to
us those are you might say not just the
raw material but the already shaped raw
material that then the virtues if we're
doing well or the vices if we're going
poorly come in and shape some more and
consolidate into fixed patterns so that
the virtuous person in feeling emotions
is in fact doing something natural but
they're doing something natural in a way
that now has been trained in certain
ways so again to take anger it's natural
to feel anger when people bump into us
and they think that they're being
careless we don't have to allow that to
automatically flare up into a rage and
we can learn tech techniques then when
they become the vitual
when they become part of our second
nature help us to not feel angry and to
become as aristotle says more forgiving
or excusing tsunami came
in the Greek and we can similarly say so
for every one of the other virtues that
he has to do with emotions or with
desires we could say similarly with with
virtues that pertain primarily to
actions and goods those we have the
potential for but they have to be
actualized through activity which
eventually leads to a finished habit
within us